the scp foundation's mobile task forces
are the best of the best their members
are the elite hand-picked from the
world's militaries intelligence agencies
security contractors and navies to
create the foundation's own security
force they ensure that the other
personnel are able to do their jobs
without having to worry about their own
safety whether it be during an assault
on the site from the chaos insurgency or
a containment breach from one of the
countless dangerous anomalies that the
foundation contains
of course not every mobile task force
can do everything that's why each one is
specialized highly trained and equipped
with bleeding edge technology and
equipment every mobile task force has
one specialty one thing they do better
than anyone else in the world and with
the hundreds of mobile task forces on
the foundation's roster that's quite a
few specialties there's the famous mtf
epsilon 11 the nine-tailed foxes
handling internal foundation security
this military task force is made up of
former special operations soldiers and
are deployed into foundation sites
usually when something has gone terribly
wrong to clean up the mess and restore
order whenever a containment breach or
communication blackout happens epsilon
11 won't be far behind or you can take
the grizzled mtf zeta 9 the molerats
specially trained to explore map contain
and if necessary fight enclosed
subterranean spaces and anomalous
topographies zeta9 has a high casualty
rate but if they can't dive into the
darkness to get the job done nobody can
and who can forget the infamous mtf
omega 7 pandora's box a secret task
force organized in the 90s to train and
utilize humanoid scp objects in field
operations for the foundation some of
the most famous humanoid anomalies like
scp-076 were members of omega-7 until it
was forcibly disbanded by o5 command but
that's a story for another day but above
all these task forces one mtf operates
on another level the o5 council the
group of 13 mysterious individuals that
control the foundation retain one mobile
task force for their personal use mobile
task force alpha one the red right hand
named for the biblical symbol of
vengeance alpha one serves appropriately
as the right hand of the overseers
executing their edicts throughout the
foundation their operations are
classified so intensely one could be
mistaken for thinking they don't even
really exist but alpha one embodied the
will of the overseers and are empowered
to enforce that will by any means
necessary most foundation personnel will
never even encounter alpha 1 throughout
their entire career and if they do it
generally means that something has gone
very very awry and for the few select
personnel that get the opportunity to
join mtf alpha 1 they'll be put through
rigorous physical psychological and
anomalous screening before even being
considered to have their identity and
existence redacted from society and
being pressed into service but what
exactly does mtf alpha 1 do how are
their members selected today we're going
to look at the story of one such recruit
to join the foundation's most elite task
force
d-0912 formerly known as one andrew
carter was unceremoniously forced out of
his cell one morning and grabbed around
the arms by the tall imposing armored
guards of the foundation the test
subject was then made to walk down to
the halls of the site down an elevator
through several wings until they reached
a door then from inside he heard a voice
step forward
d-0912 so he stepped through the
threshold of the door into the sterile
white testing chamber aside from a
single metal chair in the middle of the
room under one harsh white light it was
completely empty the shadows made it
hard to see the corners of the room
behind him a doctor who followed him
into the room with a clipboard and lab
coat wrote something down while speaking
in a low monotone voice you will be
vaccinated against an anomalous pathogen
later we will conduct tests of the
vaccine's effectiveness sit in the chair
before i even thought of running the two
guards flanked the door their faces were
covered by black visors and he could see
his own reflection in them daydreaming
to himself he slowly moved toward the
chair he thought about gods and beasts
and blood how the foundation seemed to
suck up test subjects for its own
purposes the way an old god sucked up
sacrifices and left empty corpses behind
he heard footsteps sit in the chair
d0912 he was barely sat for a few
seconds when the guard stepped forward
and used the leather straps to tie his
hands to the arms of the chair then he
tried to think why was he here why was
he in this jumpsuit he couldn't remember
he had a faint memory of a crime being
committed maybe murder but who knew why
did the foundation care he kept
wondering about it more and more he had
no idea who was in his family or what
his life had once been just that he'd
committed a crime once but if he was
guilty of something how the foundation
gotten its hands on him there aren't
many death row prisoners in the world
and society keeps a close eye on them to
make sure justice is served why would
the foundation pick the most closely
monitored prisoners for their sacrifices
it doesn't make sense what made even
less sense was the foundation entrusting
the job to prisoners with little
education and few specialized skills
experiments require precision and
finesse and manual labor could be
handled using machines or drones for
explanation it seemed idiotic to have
thugs and criminals do the work of
unraveling the mysteries of the world
just when d-0912 started to wonder about
how he even learned to think this while
in jail someone interrupted his reverie
d-0912
the doctor in the lab code said he
responded from the chair you're giving
me a vaccination
that's right the man said not looking at
d0912 good day to give somebody a
vaccination isn't it d0912 knew what
happened to d-classes on a monthly basis
he knew he wasn't being vaccinated for
anything ar are you sure you can't make
more use of me why would you throw away
a tool for the greater good so easily
d0912 asked i don't know what you're
talking about the man in the lab coat
replied but between the guards at the
door the restraints on the chair in the
middle of the room and the doctor's
impassive face d0912 knew he was being
put to death he wriggled his arms
pointing out that the straps were loose
but the doctor ignored him d-0912
couldn't figure out why he wasn't scared
of his impending death or why he was so
nonchalant about it pieces of his mind
seemed to be missing his past had been
ripped away from him and his future
turned in on itself try as he might he
couldn't remember anything about his
life before his tenure in the
foundation's d-class program he decided
that he might never have even been alive
and that's why he couldn't remember
anything surprisingly he also didn't
hate the foundation for killing him the
foundation was a massive organization it
didn't hate him it just needed him for a
little while and didn't anymore but the
little people like the doctors and
researchers and guards who made his life
a living hell by poking and prodding and
shoving and threatening him bothered him
these people were his only connection to
other humans and they were wasting his
potential
d-0912 started daydreaming again as the
doctor in the lab coat worked he
imagined men chopping wood and carving
stone to build the tower to reach the
sky were the wood and stone being
destroyed as they were stacked on one
another or were they always destined to
be part of the tower when finery and
silk clothing was presented to an
emperor have the silkworms known their
products would one day wind up on the
most powerful man in the world he was
broken out of the reverie again by the
doctor lifting up his sleeve carrying a
syringe in his other hand the tip was
long thin imperceptible and impossibly
sharp then it pricked into d0912's skin
and he began to shudder it felt warm and
hot and shook him inside and flowed up
into his brain everything turned white
and the room seemed to disintegrate into
particles around him but he noticed a
presence overhead draped in white
clothes and sensed the two guards
looking at each other exchanging a
glance and nodding he managed to get a
few words out
st stop this
oh god then he fell back into his mind
navigating out of the confusing messy
dark maze inside his head he couldn't
see the light to the path only smoking
chemical fire until he was totally lost
and heard screaming and roaring as the
beasts began to roar inside its head
d0912
remembered he remembered his name andrew
carter he remembered being told by a man
in the lab coat that he had a unique
opportunity to redeem himself by
participating in the scp foundation's
d-class personnel program for one month
you earn your freedom for a second he
almost agreed to it until his mind
remembered
you're lying i'm not a criminal no the
man said you're not but i wasn't lying
you need redemption
d0912 responded i won't be told that i
need redemption from people who detain
experiment on and torture the innocent
you violated me you made my own brain
lie to itself you had me pretend to be a
criminal the man laughed at him and
pointed out the obvious he had believed
the lie how can you say who you are when
you can't even remember your own past
how does he even know his mind is his
own why is it bad for the foundation to
mess with something andrew carter
doesn't own they argued for a few more
minutes andrew insisted he was himself
and the man in the lab coat expected him
to know his function being a sacrifice
for the foundation's greater good then
d0912 asked who the man in the lab coat
was and the lab coat suddenly dissolved
away he realized he was hallucinating
again and had been hallucinating this
entire time the man's eyes turned into
bright orange lanterns and his chest
cracked and peeled and rised this wasn't
a man
this was a beast the beast told him that
if he did not know who he was his
sacrifice would be meaningless that he
would have to realize what he was before
he could be redeemed i will not be a
sacrifice
d0912 said the beast laughed in his face
and a thousand voices left right
alongside it then the scene changed and
he was somewhere else some kind of dirt
road with a long metal chain-link fence
stretching across the horizon every so
often there was a guard tower by the
fence he was standing in front of a gate
with the two guards from the room
standing behind him the electric fence's
gate swung open to him and the guards
behind him spoke the guard on the left
commanded him to enter the gate and he
took a step and stopped no i've been
here before you made me do this and then
made me forget i did this already the
guard on the right just raised a gun to
andrew carter's head if you did not
comply we will shoot then
shoot me already d0912 said he knew that
he had been here before already
countless times and the foundation had
amnesticized him over and over and over
again but this time he remembered that
his name was andrew carter and they had
spent too much time in the hallucination
something was different this time around
as the echoes of a gunshot rang through
the air d-0912 collapsed to the ground
he saw through the gate to the village
beyond numbers flew through the air and
wrapped themselves around the villagers
they were marching row by row just as he
had seen them do time and time again he
remembered feeling the numbers slide
into his own brain they had formed
expressions and equations that blossomed
into a billion different right and wrong
evaluations as truth and falsehood were
demoted to special cases of general
chaos he said the words then my name is
andrew carter the words made a sign and
in all signs there was power but the
numbers and equations that proliferated
in the air had power of their own they
formed rows and columns and if d0912
looked at them from far enough away
there was a sign written in the pattern
of the numbers he had seen the sign
again and again and the foundation had
made his mind forget it again and again
so his mind went chasing after the sign
and the source of the sign's power until
he eventually found it wrapped it up in
the branches of a wild apple tree hidden
where no human eyes had wandered the
hallucination was getting more intense
and he could feel his brain falling
apart with the pressure the guards
walked over and knelt down by his sides
what do you see one of them asked as he
laid on the ground he tried to remember
what he saw but couldn't describe it it
was like a power tool without someone
holding it it didn't know what it was or
who made it but it still knew its
purpose the other guard spoke but if you
have no marker how do you know what your
purpose is then something clicked in
d0912's tortured brain where he was
still navigating the forest maze in his
mind all the dark confusing paths slowly
merged together at the center of the
maze and he knew that the answer to the
riddle was there
in the center of his head between the
beasts and the forests it was his name
andrew carter as he got closer to the
answer some things began to make more
sense to his mind there were two worlds
there was one world in which roads and
buildings ran straight and clouds
drifted across the sky and set paths and
the earth rotated peacefully around a
tranquil sun there was another world
where singularities and vacuums shatter
the underpinnings of the universe where
fractal patterns spread out across the
ground and radiated like halos from the
unthinkable minds of human beings and
the roads diverged from one another in
angles and spirals it was the first
world where the foundation thought only
about costs and benefits and how to best
maximize utility for seven billion
people and where no matter what the
foundation was the greater good he had
lived his old life in the first world
and was only now seeing the second world
for what it really was
the truth the foundation had long since
abandoned trying to describe itself to
others so there was no truth to what the
foundation was it just was and always
would be as he came to this conclusion
d0912 looked into himself in his
hallucinatory state he could see the
chemical light substance that the doctor
had injected into his bloodstream the
chemical reactions weren't what he was
expecting this chemical couldn't
possibly kill him in fact it was a
little similar to the chemical structure
of the molecules of the amnestics he had
been pumped with a dozen times before
but slightly different he knew he was
going to live outside of andrew carter's
mind the doctor was looking over his
perfectly still body when one of the
guards spoke again dr wayne wright said
the guard on the right yes sir the
doctor responded leave us now the guard
said yes sir the doctor lowered his eyes
to look at the floor as he quickly
shuffled out of the room the guard on
the left adjusted his visor to make
direct eye contact with the guard on the
right hey he said smiling look he took
out a syringe of red liquid from behind
his back the guard on the right
responded do not implicate me in your
misdemeanors adam the guard with the
syringe and hand snapped back don't
blame me for trying to share the guard
on the right looked at him upset and
said you are to find site director and
return that to him immediately petty
theft from foundation employees who know
no better is rather distasteful
furthermore helmets is a level 5
controlled substance its unregulated
distribution is punishable it's fine
adam said slipping the syringe into his
pocket i'll let the go between no and
he'll tell the o5s jesus bason do you
really think i'd let the o5s lose track
of some of their helmets in the chair in
front of them d0912's body convulsed a
low groan escaped his frothy lips
immediately the two guards moved
forwards and removed his restraints
andrew carter the psalmist slowly d0912
opened his eyes
you didn't kill me we were not planning
to do so bassam said d0912 continued you
took me from the real world in order to
make me into something direct
uncontrolled exposure to the
foundation's anomalies repeated
anesthetization leading me to believe
that i would eventually be killed also
that my mind would be in the perfect
position for the foundation to change it
with whatever whatever's in that man's
pocket d0912 extended a finger at adam
who offered a faint smile back already
knowing things that you shouldn't know
aren't you precious adam said you have
been altered bassam said to meet the
specifications of a top secret project
over the course of your future you will
learn more about the foundation than any
of your previous jailers ever knew or
could have hoped to guess at you will
join a group that is at the very head of
the foundation for your entire life this
has been your purpose d0912 felt the
rotting flesh of the now dead disguise
that had hidden andrew carter fall away
but som continued welcome to mobile task
force alpha one now go check out scp
elite mobile task force explained and
mtf tau5 samsara tale avatara for more
scp foundation mobile task force madness
from scp explained